all right so we all know that Apple's
custom arm silicone base Macs are coming
soon
but since they mentioned that there are
still more Intel based Mac's in the
pipeline it's really hard to tell which
Mac's will get released and when during
this two-year transition period that
Apple gave us so in this video I'm gonna
gather up all of the leaks and rumors we
currently have to try and figure out
what Apple's Mac release timeline will
look like over the next two years now
it's very important to realize that the
two-year transition does not mean that
Apple absolutely has to update every
single Mac before the two years are up
it simply means that after two years we
should not expect to see any new
intel-based Macs but before we get into
the video be sure to check out our Apple
product merch right below this video
first I'm gonna start with the last few
Macs ever that will ship with Intel
processors as you probably already know
Apple's 27-inch iMac is in a really
weird spot right now because current
delivery dates are all the way out into
September which is absolutely ridiculous
this points to a refresh coming very
soon and I personally think it'll be
within the next couple of weeks and
recently we saw new leaked benchmarks of
an iMac with a 10 core eye 9 Intel
processor and a new Radeon pro graphics
chip so this gives us further evidence
that an Intel based Mac is coming soon
and by the way don't expect any major
design changes since Apple will most
likely keep any redesigns for their arm
base Macs
now there's also the chance that Apple
will update the iMac pro just one more
time at the end of this year with an
Intel processor most likely a new big
navvy graphics card and a mini LED
display which will give Apple more time
before they have to update it again with
an apple silicon chip in the future now
as far as the Mac books the only one
that might get a refresh with an Intel
chip is the 16 inch MacBook Pro there is
a chance that this fall
Apple will quietly update the 16 inch
MacBook Pro with a 10th gen minor
updates like the possibility of Wi-Fi 6
but don't expect any major design
changes now as far as the lower end Macs
like the Mac Mini the MacBook Air and
the 13-inch MacBook Pro I don't expect
those machines to get refreshed with
intel chips anymore I'm almost 100%
positive that the next models will get
Apple silicon the only mac left is the
Mac Pro and what I think Apple is gonna
do is release an Intel based Mac Pro
right before the two-year transition
period is over now moving on to the
release timeline of Apple silicon Mac's
the first one that we should expect is
the fully redesigned 24 inch iMac and
rumors are pointing to the release date
being between October and the end of the
year I personally think that Apple is
gonna host an online-only October event
where they'll release some Apple silicon
Macs and potentially other Apple
products like a new Apple TV 4k and an
iPad air for now alongside the 24 inch
iMac we should also expect a new Apple
silicon macbook most rumors are pointing
to it being a 13-inch MacBook Pro which
will most likely replace the current
$1300 base model now this makes sense
because it was the only 13-inch MacBook
that didn't get updated to an Intel 10th
gen processor sticking to an outdated
hñ chip and as far as the Apple silicon
MacBook Air the reputable analyst means
you quo thinks that it'll either come in
the fourth quarter of this year or the
first quarter of next year and either of
those dates would make sense so the
lower end Mac's which are aimed at the
casual market of users will be released
first giving Apple and developers more
time to optimize performance before the
higher-end Mac's get updated so let's
get right into those it's now pretty
clear that the long-awaited 14 inch
MacBook Pro redesign is gonna pack Apple
silicon and I think it's going to be the
$1,800 model exclusively and I think
it's gonna be released alongside the 16
inch macbook pro also with apple silicon
and they'll both probably come with new
mini LED displays as far as the release
date rumors are pointing to them getting
released anywhere from june 2021 to the
end of september but it may even be
released at Apple's 2021 October event
now as far as the Mac
Meeny it's in a pretty weird spot since
it's on the cheaper side but it's also
used by professionals and then there's
also the fact that Apple used it for
their developer transition kids but
since we haven't heard any rumors about
the Apple silicon version coming anytime
soon
I'd place my bets on it getting released
sometime late next year since that's
when the last three Mac Mini models were
released now as far as the higher-end 5k
iMac there's a chance that Apple might
not even update it with an ARM based
chip until 2022 past the two-year
transition period since it's used by a
lot of high-end professionals but on the
other hand it would definitely be weird
for the 24 inch iMac to be using Apple
silicon for two full years while the 27
inch is still on Intel so for that
reason I think we'll see a full redesign
with a mini LED display and ARM based
chip in the spring or summer of next
year and then there's the iMac Pro and I
personally think Apple could potentially
wait until 2023 to finally update it
again with Apple silicon since they need
the extra time to get it optimized
before bringing it to the high-end
market and the only Mac left is the Mac
Pro and since that Mac is meant to be
upgradable I think Apple won't update it
with an ARM based chip until at least
2020 3 or 2024 and at that point they'll
either come out with their own Apple
dedicated GPUs or they'll find some sort
of way to have ARM based add-in cards
that are replaceable one of our viewers
mentioned something about CCI X allowing
you to interconnect the main central
chip and various dedicated accelerator
cards without losing much bandwidth now
I don't really know much about this but
it would totally make sense for Apple to
use this in their arm powered Mac Pro so
there you guys have it that's how I
think Apple will handle their transition
to their Apple silicon if this video is
helpful be sure to tap the like button
below and click that circle above to
subscribe thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
[Music]